aquí tenemos tres problemas la idea no
es resolverlos sino únicamente plantear
ecuaciones que después se pueden
trabajar para obtener la respuesta bueno
para plantear esas ecuaciones vamos a
utilizar proporciones déjame ver esto
con el primer problema dice lo siguiente
nueve marcadores cuestan 115 pesos
cuánto cuestan 7 marcadores como nos
preguntan cuánto cuestan 7 marcadores
voy a llamar x al costo de 7 marcadores
entonces x es igual es igual al costo
costo de 7 marcadores 7 marcadores
marcadores muy bien entonces vamos a
plantear dos proporciones y las vamos a
igualar y esas proporciones van a ser de
marcadores a costo entonces aquí tenemos
9 marcadores 9 marcadores y el costo es
entonces nuestra primer proporción va a
ser 9 la cantidad de marcadores entre su
costo 115
y esa proporción debe ser igual a la
cantidad de marcadores de este lado a 7
entre su costo que le pusimos x / x esta
igualdad también se puede escribir de
otra forma volteando las proporciones de
ambos lados de la igualdad es decir se
puede poner como 115 el costo de 9
marcadores entre 9 marcadores es igual a
x el costo de 7 marcadores entre 7
marcadores para estas dos de aquí son
equivalentes pero hay todavía otra forma
de pensar este problema de proporciones
y es haciendo proporciones de marcadores
e igualar las a una proporción de
precios es decir podemos ponerle 9
marcadores entre 7 marcadores es igual
al costo de 9 marcadores 115 entre el
costo de x marcadores y por supuesto
aquí también se pueden voltear a ambos
lados de la igualdad así que se puede
poner que 7 marcadores entre 9
marcadores es igual al costo de 7
marcadores o sea x
entre el costo de nueve marcadores que
es 115 muy bien entonces cualquiera de
estas ecuaciones es válida y es una
forma de plantear nuestro problema en
proporciones después se puede trabajar
con estas para despejar x pero ahorita
no lo vamos a hacer vamos a pasar al
segundo problema bueno este problema
dice siete manzanas cuestan 50 pesos voy
a poner las manzanas en rosa y el costo
en azul cuantas manzanas puedo comprar
con 80 pesos entonces nos preguntan por
cuantas manzanas esto es lo que nos
preguntan vamos a llamarle x puedo
comprar con 80 pesos
misma idea vamos a hacer una proporción
de manzanas a precio entonces siete
manzanas entre su precio entre su costo
le voy a poner aquí entre 50 es igual a
equis manzanas x manzanas entre su costo
o sea si puedo comprar x manzanas con 80
pesos el costo de x manzanas es 80
entonces aquí sería x entre 80 muy bien
otra forma de pensarlo es hacer una
proporción de manzanas es decir poner
siete manzanas entre x manzanas y eso
igualarlo a la proporción de precios
correspondientes es decir 50 el costo de
siete manzanas entre el costo de x
manzanas muy bien y claro cualquiera de
estas dos también se puede voltear de
ambos lados y obtendríamos otras dos
ecuaciones que también son válidas a
partir de las cuales se puede encontrar
el valor de x bueno vamos con el tercer
problema dice lo siguiente una receta de
pastel para cinco personas voy a marcar
en naranja las personas requiere dos
huevos
voy a poner en rojo cuántos huevos esto
es lo que nos preguntan requiere una
receta para 15 personas 15 personas
bueno aquí nos preguntan cuántos huevos
entonces déjame ponerle un nombre a esa
variable otra vez le voy a poner x le
podría poner h bueno a lo mejor h no es
buena idea porque se puede confundir con
una altura que se usa mucho en
matemáticas pero le podría poner a v o
te lo que sea pero déjame ponerle x vale
entonces vamos a plantear las
proporciones ahora va a ser proporción
de personas a huevos entonces dice 5 en
una receta de 5 personas requiere dos
huevos entonces 5 entre 2 y eso lo
tenemos que igualar esta proporción la
tenemos que igualar
a 15 personas una receta de 15 personas
cuántos huevos requiere entonces la
cantidad de huevos que requiere una
receta de 15 personas es decir x y ahí
tenemos ya planteada una ecuación otra
forma de pensarlo es con una proporción
de personas es decir poniendo 5 personas
entre 15 personas y del lado derecho
poner la cantidad de huevos que requiere
la receta para 5 personas o sean 2 y
podemos y hay que dividir entre la
cantidad de huevos que requiere la
receta para 15 personas es decir entre x
muy bien y con esto ya planteamos dos
ecuaciones podríamos plantear otras dos
volteando ambos lados de la igualdad
pero vaya ya tenemos ecuaciones válidas
para resolver el problema por ejemplo
aquí podríamos multiplicar por 80 y así
podríamos encontrar x y con eso
obtendríamos la respuesta y se puede
hacer lo mismo en cada uno de estos
problemas bueno espero que te haya
gustado nos vemos hasta la próxima